bienvenue à celui où débute notre
histoire
qu'est ce que tu as inventé un message
dans une bouteille
je me suis échoué venez à mon shopping
les mystérieuses mais casser mes bougies
mais savez-vous que parfois les graines
les plus petites peuvent grandir paix et
mesurer mon aile et si quintais c'que ça
c'est moi le professeur glucose
mais c'est une poire géante quand un ami
a besoin de vous tous les moyens sont
bons
sébastien lapointe est ambato opus henri
gibert allemand ceci est une des seules
par ilic 400 libre
à
[Musique]
tous les sept points chèrement
attends moi
jb
tessier
sebastian
si toi aussi tu es prêt à tout pour
sauver ton meilleur ami
[Musique]
bon d'abord de la poêle géante pour un
voyage extraordinaire
li mystérieuse
[Musique]
mika et sebastian laventure de la poêle
géante quelle folle aventure